Jessica Simpson because she is going
into detail about her alcohol addiction
and just how deep it got I always had a
glitter cup and it was always filled to
the rim but with alcohol I had started a
spiral and I couldn't catch up with
myself Jess's drinking was so out of
control she now admits to hitting the
bottle before this 2017 interview with
Ellen have you written a song yet or
you're just starting I have about I
probably have about 38 so maybe 36 39 I
can't even watch the interview like I
you know it was a weak moment for me the
mom of three talks all about her new
memoir open book on The Today Show
revealing her rock bottom was getting
blackout drunk on Halloween in 2017
I was just dazed and confused and I just
wanted to go to sleep I didn't take them
trick-or-treating I didn't show up for
my family you know I took the picture
and I made the world think that I showed
up the next day she quit drinking
started therapy and has remained sober
since Eric quit the bottle to just for
his wife Jess also revealed another
addiction that started when she was
signed to a record label at 17 and told
she had to lose 15 pounds diet pills
like I didn't know what I was doing I
didn't know how much I was taking it
ended up being something I did for 20
years and when it comes to her marriage
with Nick Lachey my dad thought I was
too young I was about to walk down the
aisle he's like we don't have to do this
like dad what are you talking about we
got a walk
[Music]